pour la toute première fois une série
télévisée québécoise était présenté à la
prestigieuse berlinale un moment
étourdissant pour les créateurs de c'est
comme ça que je t'aime on sent un peu un
peu fébrile et un peu énervé mais
attention avec des ennemis
collectivement j'ai heureusement on a
fait vraiment quelque chose un bout un
beau projet ce quelque chose d'illégal
il ya comme une bonne vibe huguet à
grands coups de fusil c'est comme ça que
je t'aime se déroule en 1974 hac 5 fois
en banlieue de québec
deux couples d'amis et voisins sont sur
le bord de la rupture
il ya du sexe beaucoup de prévisions et
de la criminalité dans cette fiction des
créateurs de séries noires et des
invincibles
dans le premier épisode ils ont ça
qu'ils ont tous envie de centrer dessus
et ça va pas oublier la league cup
finalement nos professeurs ils vont
télécharger leurs leur frustration leur
violence sur les oignons piments tuer
les autres situées entre eux à berlin
malgré la barrière de la langue du sous
titre le public a très bien réagi on
embarque et je suis vraiment surpris je
suis très très heureux que présentement
chicane plus calme c'en est un
david et espère bons les jeunes il y
avait une belle qualité d'écouté
huguette huy micheline au volet moi j'ai
cette série se démarque par sa
cinématographie qui rappelle celle de
martin scorsese y de quentin tarantino
et des frères coen et pour obtenir un
résultat de calibre international
les producteurs n'ont pas lésiné sur les
moyens j'ai pris le risque de mettre les
vestiaires beaucoup dans cette série
locke parce que je trouvais que si on
fait une série d'époque qui fond qu'est
l'argent les crampes et de la production
dans l'ue mais s'ils font en plus tu es
si on veut qu'à la série se démarque
l'international
mais il faut y mettre le paquet
qui tue qui dira qu'ils veulent c'est
comme ça que je t'aime tu es parti huit
séries choisi cette année par la
berlinale qui a reçu 120 candidatures
la directrice de bergues in a series est
visiblement tombé sous le charme et 13
c'est très accepte exceptionnel je pense
la présentation à berlin 2 c'est comme
ça que je t'aime a été un succès et à sa
sortie patrice robitaille s'est même
prêtée au jeu de lego portrait avec un
admirateur avec une star à part les vous
après berlin la série c'est comme ça que
je t'aime sera présenté sur l'extra de
tou.tv à compter du 6 mars
et avec tout cet engouement de la
critique le scénariste françois
létourneau en est à l'écriture d'une
deuxième saison ici louis philippe
ouimet radio-canada berlin